but we're now going to talk about an ex
rumors which abound today and I brought
I'm not Pete you're pretty well versed
in the tech scene as your yeah tapped
into it yeah you're tapping to do it
Justin you're right about things you
know 3d s so you know exactly what we're
talking about no Nintendo so apparently
according to Eurogamer I believe had the
original yeah yeah euro gamers report
from Eurogamer tomorrow saying UK editor
at gamespot wrote this up Nintendo's
next gaming platform code name my next
will be a portable console that has
detachable controllers because that
pretty much confirms what we already
suspected right that it's going to have
nunchucks well mine is the detachable
controllers that's the weird part right
well so the the whole concept of a
detachable device like a dockable mobile
gaming thing was like kind of refuted by
some sources at one point and so for the
past few months I've been saying like no
no that's not gonna be a thing you've
kept waving that flag and I'm here to
lower my flag because it sounds like if
this is true and it probably could be
based on what they're describing it
sounds like something Nintendo would do
in some ways it sounds like what we all
thought that wii u was when it was first
announced because we had that same
confusion when they brought out the wii
u controller and we thought this is a
self-contained device in itself what an
amazing idea and now five years however
many years later like Oh still an
amazing idea please still actually do
that yeah cool it's like the wii u if
the wii u's tablet was much more like
mobile not just a portable around your
house or anything III don't understand
how the detachable controllers put
plural would work exactly peters you're
saying like what maybe like we modish
things on the side that's what it yeah
the story illustrates they just popped
up there is just sore like a little
concept right but it is you know a
analog stick at the top of a remote
looking thing and on the bottom or other
buttons or d-pad depending on which half
you're talking about so would you would
you like cradle it like play it like
this can we get a close-up on what is it
are you playing the poppet i'm playing
zelda do you like the bone arrow the
t-rex trying to play this new console so
it looks like that will be a
controllable option and some people are
talking about okay this will enable
multiplayer
on the go right because everyone will
get their own controller to hold not
everyone but you know what I'm
suspecting is that there will also be a
pro controller equivalent where you're
not going to be expected to play all
your games at home once you doc the
handheld using these to awkward things
right because when it's a handheld it's
all an attached unit and that has
inherent comfort and usability so I
think yes those controllers will be like
wiimote like things you can detach and
use in various ways but I doubt that'll
be the only controller I'm gonna call
this now i think the attached
controllers are actually going to be
maracas it's just a missive rhythm
console specifically yes I should fix
your maracas I was hoping four
harpsichords no okay anyway but so well
the other really interesting thing to me
is the confirmation that it will not I
guess not confirmation the rumor that it
will use cartridges yeah sure yeah and I
don't think it as weird as it would be
to take that step back I also don't
think it's not far-fetched what that
says to me is not necessarily that all
games will be on a cartridge but that
Nintendo will be pushing really hard for
a download based system that we will go
back to the future that xbox and
microsoft talked about years ago at the
launch of the xbox one which was shot
down I think Nintendo might go forward
with that like if you want to get every
game you're gonna have to download it
digitally I think that'll be like an
option but cartridges have an inherent
value for people who don't have access
to fast internet things like that like
they if they want this to be mainstream
and sell to a lot they have to make sure
that they're covering every segment of
the market but cartridges are expensive
ah but Justin but a optical disc right
that's right right right right no no
those are cheap telling Pete on to
optical does you watch me tell him
optical discs a lot of moving parts you
got lasers gotta move back and forth you
gotta spin the discs all this stuff
creates a lot of noise and takes a lot
of intricate you know machinery a flash
drive you know like a cartridge yes it's
a little bit more expensive to produce
but you and me but you have a thing that
is not generating a lot of heat it's not
making a lot of noise it's very simple
you just sort of read the pins on it and
there you go so I think this is more of
a move to give provide storage in a way
that makes sense for the platform that's
going to be portable rather than like
this cynical like nudge towards yeah we
just want you to download everything we
don't want to manufacture games okay I
don't think that's necessarily cynical
though I think that's going with their
with a market that we are a lot closer
to a future of high bandwidth areas
where downloading games is not seen as
something weird or strange having so
many games now that are always online
but we're based in San Francisco think
about someone in South America but think
about something like destiny like
there's so many really big game
experiences you have to be online to
play sure yeah I just can't see a
console going entirely download only
that I think there will be experienced
it and that's where the cartridge will
come in there will be experiences you
can have on a cartridge but to get a
full experience you will have to be
online for Nintendo's next console I can
see them making that if you want to get
everything if you want to be have the
full access to the library or two but
that is every system right now exactly
and it's gonna I'm just saying I think
it'll be a lot more limited in terms of
what you can get on a cartridge on what
you can get on a physical in a physical
form well that's already the story with
Wii U I'm just I'm just countering the
idea that Nintendo is just really
direction because there are no games own
with you yeah well NX that all the
report also says it will reportedly run
on a proprietary operating system
designed by Nintendo and not Android as
previous report suggests i don't really
know it probably i don't remember those
cattle room I don't know what I don't
know what reportedly means what were the
when did these reports come out that
it's gonna be Android was that oh it's
just all those rumors flying around that
have been you know there's a couple
sources on were perpetuating the talk of
rumors right now yes we are yeah yeah
people have a lot of different ideas and
sometimes they confirm them with sources
that are reputable or not well it was
weird because some of the most concrete
evidence of what the NX might be was
breadth of the while to e3 because it
kind of hinted at the fact that the NX
isn't going to be this complete
departure from a more traditional
console experience because it has like
you're playing on the wii u it has to
work for the wii UI sword for the NX and
it kind of told you a lot like about the
control scheme it's not gonna be like
something you plan your phone obviously
this game is not that that was ever like
the main concern but i don't know like
does this kind of does this new do these
new rumors kind of confirm what we
gathered from breath of the wild like
the sparse info that we could kind of
garner i I think it plays into it well
that it doesn't defy what you might
expect it for a console that will be
able to play breath of the oil because
we know breath of the wild
be a playable game on this system but it
also makes it really interesting and how
that's going to work and what kind of
experience that's going to be I don't
know what do you think Peter I don't
think it's gonna be very different from
the way your version at all well annoy
it'll be the same game yeah something if
not better yeah so Bob is your question
I'm five Bob Jones 1980 in the chat was
saying any rumors and X will require a
cellular provider it doesn't now it
doesn't sound like it right no it's not
like that kind of mobile game I think
that would mean Sony tried that with the
Vita an aveda has its own problems but
that whole initiative just proved that
that's not somehow people we don't want
that yeah sure I'm gonna so I've heard
from multiple confirmed sources
definitely that that in addition to NX
and in addition to Zelda being on NX
there's gonna be a mario game so you can
attribute that to me Justin literate
with the scoop Super Mario universe
total 16 2017 I'm getting I'm getting
another report that there will almost
really likely be a fire emblem game and
an animal crossing game for NX at some
point in the consoles life cycle uh 2016
I think he's hearing 2016 no I confirm
I'm confirming it now in 2016 it'll be
out and sometime the next 10 years okay
perfect so we're off the wait long maybe
we do maybe we don't um so obviously you
know like Nintendo did confirm the
global release day is march next year
yeah that was a couple months ago they
confirm that yeah okay so i guess we're
inching closer to finding out more about
it on your birthday maybe it might be
how do you remember my birthday month
cuz i love you everyone's born in march
my entire family is born in march gross
everyone disgusting anyway so that is
the hold on there's more to say really
talk about the thing powering this thing
oh yeah Pete hit us with that kind of
hamsters we can do we could do it hoping
you could explain it about the NX yeah I
would know and everyone do you so how
electricity works so when a proton a
neutrino okay long story short this is
jimmy tank mentioned on the lobby a
couple weeks ago this might be running
nvidia tegra processor which is a mobile
chip that is used in some phones and
tablets that's what i was going to say
that yes I need
hahaha and it's also their Android
shield a chip and that can actually run
games better than an xbox 360 and ps3 in
some instances like 1080p 60 for some
games that ran 720p 30 but not all games
like something like middle of your
rising revengeance ran slower on that
there's a version out right now called
the x1 it's pretty good that was the one
I was just describing we kind of know
that the x2 is coming it's going to have
a smaller manufacturing process
obviously be more powerful but we know
next to nothing else about it when it's
coming out if it'll be in this right now
it's targeted mostly two cars if it
sticks with the x1 and the rumors that
we're hearing today are true dev kits
have a fan built in to the thing to cool
the the chip which means you might be
playing a handheld with a fan on it in
your car unless they go to this new one
where it can dissipate heat at a much
more efficient rate we don't need that
fan so that's what those rumors are
coming from here's hoping we don't need
a fan because that would be kind of
annoying yeah be like the loud xbox one
that's not like a thing that's a my
roommate Jake Decker he has the loudest
Xbox one ever and every time he's
playing it I can hear it like from my
room beneath his so if he has another
piece of hardware that's making more
noise driving me insane I'm gonna lots
of news Hardware make noise and Jake
Decker's room yeah yeah like I don't
know we talked about this on the lobby
before I get annoyed by small noises
misophonia we don't need to get into it
Pete knows Justin knows it makes a lot
of noise I don't know I mean anyway so
that is the latest bevy of rumors about
Nintendo's NX which they have confirmed
will release in March 2017 we kind of
learned if this report is accurate we
it's not confirmed yet well a little
more about it only vegetable controllers
so yeah let us know you think are you
excited for the NX do you believe these
rumors are true I don't know tell us in
the comments below
you